j'étais à 42 semaines de grossesse
c'était dans la nuit
faisait froid dehors de la mare de sang
neuf au mois de septembre l'automne il
faisait beau un plaisir mon ex-mari
était exposé deux parties la journée la
journée de la fin puis j'ai retenu pour
qu'il laisse avec moi et m
les contractions commencé me d'énerver
aussi parce qu'on n'avait pas d'auto et
mme alliot sur ces 15 km nage de paris
iv je savais pas ce que j'allais avoir
c'est une fille ou un garçon maya s'est
présenté en octobre 2018 à l'hôpital
enceinte de son septième enfant c'était
mon deuxième le travail acquis d'avancé
très bien un travail qui se passait
relativement normalement
éventuellement ça stanier le médecin en
trip d'enlever son manteau puis voyez le
début ça surprend bertin
l'obstétricienne jeu nicolas quitter ce
rappel est venu sur les lieux parce
qu'on lui a demandé une consultation
et a commencé à parler de césariennes et
du fait même on pendant la césarienne on
pourrait vous faire une ligature des
trompes
elle a dit non si j'ai signé comme quoi
que j'étais d'accord d'envoi césarienne
j'ai signant même un lot de papier pour
indicateurs avant de partir
je l'a pas rendu à arriver
c'est mélanie très chanceuse j'arrête la
place cet après midi jeux pourquoi mais
pour te faire une ligature des fonds
diminue de penser à cela c'est une
question de
ma ville
moi j'ai pas le temps de réfléchir parce
que j'avais déjà mes contractions film
c'est quand est un mal que c'est pas le
temps de réfléchir
pour elle elle ait subi une césarienne
puis ça s'arrête là elle ne se doutait
aucunement quand lui avait clips et les
trompes
tu en prennes d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore
il y en a d'autres
on va les découvrir
moment et ariane metellus je suis
accompagnantes périnatale mère de cinq
enfants et militante en venir à
accompagner des femmes racisées c'est à
partir de mon expérience de mes
expériences de grossesse et
d'accouchement
nous avons fait appel à ariane metellus
dans la foulée de la mort de joyce et
chaque one ont cherché à documenter les
inégalités en milieu médical ariane
connaît le sujet elle collabore à une
recherche pancanadien en santé
maternelle
je sais que dans les communautés noires
particulièrement il se passe des choses
je sais que les femmes vivent des choses
ça va de
du regard ça va des lis les commentaires
avouons cbrne afrique écoutez madame on
n'est pas dans la jungle a ici
[Musique]
je me sens intéressé en fait aux
violences obstétricales en général avant
de m'intéresser
particulièrement aux stérilisations non
consenti
ce qu'elle a découvert nous a misé sur
une piste inattendue ça a été le point
de départ de notre enquête des femmes
noires ici à montréal serez stériliser
son europe les consentements se seraient
arrivés à marjah aussi récemment qu'en
2018 le cas de maria
mariam a été référée par une
professionnelle la santé qui a travaillé
avec elle auprès d'elle on sait maria
c'était son septième
sa septième grossesse
c'est une femme noire
d'un certain âge ce qui est déplorable
c'est que
maria s'attendait pas à voir une
césarienne donc là non seulement on lui
annonce que ballack va devoir avoir une
césarienne au plus bas et de oui en même
temps on peut profiter pour faire une
ligature tubert on a rencontré n'a rien
c'est un nom fictif et vous ne verrez
pas le plaisir de rencontrer et merci
d'être là et les trop bouleversée pour
témoigner à visage découvert mais elle a
accepté de nous raconter sa version de
l'histoire elle donne aux a dit à l'ats
du bord on va fait non 1 allez gatif
détrompent
j'ai dit mais tu vas fait une césarienne
est négatif des pompiers croix
elle a dit il s'est passé quoi ils
allaient gatif des tombes j'ai dû me
nomades news pas là dit oui les choses
tu fais les bébés les césariennes pas de
problème
mais pour faire les allégations des tons
passager doit parler c'est mon médecin
famille qui doit expliquer moi ça on
peut mettre ça sera un problème de
langue un manque de communication
un malentendu
mais je pense que ça va un petit peu
plus loin que ça je pense qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de
paternalisme et d'infantilisation
on sait ce qui est bon pour toi
donc beaucoup de douleur oui
ça va faire trois ans là bientôt qui
elle en parle encore avec souffrance
elle en parle elle l ensemble l ampleur
des piles et angers a beaucoup de
tristesse
ga beaucoup décoller mais je sais j je
vais demander à l pourquoi elle apprend
son décision
pour moi même
s comme
oui j'en ai entendu des histoires pour
moi le cas de maria n'était qu'une
confirmation on l'entend dans les
communautés autochtones ici au canada au
canada
le cas de maria et îles isolées
pourrait-il y avoir relié entre la
stérilisation imposé à une femme noire à
montréal et celle subie par une centaine
de femmes autochtones dans l'ouest
canadien on s'est rendu à saskatoon où
ce scandale a éclaté au grand jour en
jeune femme réclame maintenant
réparation dans le cadre d'une demande
d'autorisation d'action collective
à je m'appelle aller salon bord je suis
l'avocat qui mène le recours collectif
pour les femmes autochtones qui ont été
stérilisés sans leur consentement au
manitoba et en saskatchewan
je suis maman à deux petites filles
mariées avec un homme crie je suis
d'héritage big man et acadia
j'aurai reçu un appel d'une femme qui
m'aurait dit
ceci c'est mal ça m'est arrivé j'étais
donné naissance à mon bébé et puis j'en
suis sorti stérilisés je me suis dit bon
ça se peut pas
when she just take that i'm
black and i'm not respect the king and i
met
your mother
[Musique]
il faut que le foot
les commentaires sur les arcs ce
qu'était vraiment perturbant croyez pas
ça se peut pas il doit avoir une raison
elle se trompe à mâcon prix
alors c'était cinq heures de discours
qu'on attendait ou ou bon à plusieurs
d'autres propos racistes et
stéréotypique qui est anciennement qui
suggérerait que les femmes le mérite
chez
les femmes on commence à en parler et
puis après ça il y avait une femme et
une autre femme et une autre femme une
autre femme moyens prends comme un conte
bien avant qu'on commence à changer les
affaires c'est pas le gros qui manque de
droits sur le consentement est très très
clair alors il ya madame qui est au
travail sa capacité est bon on doit
comprendre impacté
par l'état dans laquelle elle se trouve
en couleur et c'est alors la coercition
il en faut pas beaucoup 1 dans cet étau
l'heure on peut dire bon je pense que
vous devriez faire ça ok ce que vous
dites je vais le faire mais ça c'est le
problème c'est que cela ce n'est pas le
consentement éclairé
elle me bat
avec
un
succès car c'est un environnement qui
est approprié pour considérer les
formations qu'on reçoit le son médecin
alors les risques les options les
conséquences les bénéfices etc alors
nous on dit une femme qui est en plein
travail est en train d'avoir un bébé ne
peut pas consentir à
une stérilisation permanent ou semi
permanent il y a rien d'urgent il y a
rien de thérapeutique il n'y a rien de
médicaments nécessaires
qui sont plus susceptibles d'être visées
par cette pratique qui sont ces femmes
les minorités visibles
les minorités visibles jours c'est une
question de la couleur de la peau et de
la race que le médecin ou à votre député
et je me suis dit ça peut m'arriver à
moi aussi facilement ça peut arriver à
mes filles ça peut arriver à ma belle
soeur ça peut arriver mais ni s
l'objectif de recours collectif
traditionnellement c'est la modification
du comportement alors c'est ce qu'on
cherche en premier
[Musique]
c'était au temps on appelait encore les
inuit des eskimos il y avait un curé le
père le chat qui a fait des sorties
publiques inflammé pour dénoncer les
stérilisations forcées que subissaient
les femmes dans le grand nord et vous
savez quoi
c'est encore d'actualité
bonjour aujourd'hui à la nationale 2
présent nous allons voir comment le
gouvernement fédéral pratique le
génocide des inuit
[Musique]
il part au monde connais ton un peuple
dont le tiers des femmes en âge de
procréer soit systématiquement
stérilisés pour comprendre il faut dire
d'abord que l'homme qu'on vient
d'entendre et le père robert le choc et
curé à igloolik dans les territoires du
nord-ouest et que les femmes dont il
parle sont les inuit communément appelée
esquimaude d'un sud
[Musique]
il y avait un prêtre il travaillé dans
plusieurs de ces communautés inuites il
a dénoncé ce qu'il voyait comme des
stérilisations forcées il avait dit je
passe des consentements extorqué c'était
ces mots mon nom et sa mère janine saine
je suis enfant ni en fait de parents
immigrants moi-même coucheries collomb
je suis pédiatre urgentiste
samir a découvert la croisade du père le
chat en menant sa propre enquête sur les
pratiques coloniales en milieu médical
par chance on a déniché une entrevue
avec les missionnaires dans les archives
de radio-canada il y à presque 50 ans le
père le ch a exposé son idée sur les
véritables motifs derrière les
stérilisations et posé ville voyez ça
dans un contexte où il disait que le
gouvernement fédéral ne voulait pas
payer pour ces personnes-là les enfants
qui allait naître mais pour lui c'est
toujours une question à ces politiques
qui voulaient dénoncer
à votre avis quelle est la raison qui
pousse le gouvernement fédéral à vouloir
réduire le nombre d enfants par famille
skis monde
[Musique]
sait aussi ancrée dans un contexte plus
large de colonialisme canadien qui
existaient qui avait pur pour but de
éliminé en fait les autochtones les
collectivités autochtones
d'accaparer leurs terres et leurs
ressources le projet ça a toujours été
motivé cette passe
mais quelle raison est ce qu'on donne
aux femmes pour leur proposer la
stérilisation
[Musique]
sais pas
pourquoi c'est que je puis affirmer avec
certitude c'est que je pourrais être 99
en éclats ce n'est pas la femme que la
première demain
[Musique]
et ils nous faisaient à bâle médecin il
me fait départ quand même lente et a eu
deux enfants déjà
racheté une indifférence le troisième
set
dangereux pour toi seul enfant un beau
move et aux toitures des complications
c'est dangereux vous pouvez pas voir
d'autres bébés
vous allez mourir si vous avez un bébé
là vous avez déjà des enfants qui sont à
la guerre de l'état s'est pas déjà assez
on sait bien que on vous allez finir
dans l'alcool dans la consommation pis
tout six minutes d'arrêt depuis que
thain et puis tous les pères des enfants
ben là c'est assez
puissamment bref on embête des enfants
mais si elles veulent pas arrêter de
faire des enfants
mais nous on va s'en occuper
puis saviem chercher aussi parce que moi
aussi j'ai beaucoup d'enfants
c'est là j'en suis à cinq et je les
entends ces commentaires il ya vraiment
commune on dirait presque une intention
de persuader avec la honte
ce
[Musique]
qui a été dit dans la vidéo just en fait
pour moi c'était très clair que c'est
juste quelque chose que beaucoup
de personnes dans le milieu de la santé
pense qu'ils vont peut-être pas le dire
explicitement mais ça se reflète dans
leurs gestes puis dans leurs
interventions
en remontant le fil de l'histoire on se
rend compte que les stérilisations
imposé font partie de tout un chapitre
honteux de notre passé le contrôle des
naissances est à la base de l'eugénisme
cette idée de supériorité génétique qui
a mené à l'horreur des camps de
concentration plusieurs d'entre nous
ignorent que pendant longtemps ici au
canada on a aussi pratiqué l'eugénisme
en toute impunité
entre 1920 jusqu'en 1970 il y avait deux
lois qui ont été adoptées en
colombie-britannique et en alberta
des lois sur la stérilisation et puis
souvent qu'on parle de ces civilisations
parle des personnes hongrie mais
handicapé mental on voyait des centaines
et des centaines de ces personnes là qui
est testé risée mais ce qui est clair
c'est que les femmes et les filles
autochtones était impacté de façon
disproportionnée puis dans les autres
provinces il y avait quand même des
mouvements semblables inspiré par le
juge du génie sme
en 1970 le député néo démocrate david
luiz interpelle le ministre responsable
de l'époque jean chrétien sur cette
question
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que l'afer est
évoquée au parlement le gouvernement se
contente de minimiser le problème
donc les pratiques de stérilisation
forcée et corrective continuer
dans certains hôpitaux indiens par
exemple la chose comme ça la mitaine
en 1973 des révélations de siby s'ils
confirment l'existence de consignes pour
stériliser des femmes autochtones le
mémo
mais toujours pas de réponse du
gouvernement
puis en 1976 le père le chat publie sa
série d'articles trois fois on dénombre
trois choix sans conséquence or à ce
jour personne du ministère fédéral de la
santé ou du ministère des affaires
indiennes et du nord n'a daigné répondre
ou démentir les accusations qui découle
forcément de cet état de fait à savoir
que le gouvernement fédéral est en train
de pratiquer de génocide une population
autochtone du grand nord
c'est révoltant que il ya eu des gens
qui dénoncent cette réalité depuis
maintenant des décennies
et que on est encore là à plusieurs
égards ces pratiques ont continué d'une
façon ou d'une autre en fait c'était
juste peut-être un peu plus se cacher
plus subtil disons ça a continué
ailleurs au pays ça fait plus de cinq
ans qu'on a reconnu qu'il y avait eu des
codes stérilisation forcée mais au
québec à ce jour encore ou qu'un état
des lieux a été dressé on a cru que
c'était différent erreur voici ce qu'on
a découvert
ça fait maintenant des mois car yann
nous a misé sur les pistes des
stérilisations non consenti
notre enquête nous mène aux quatre coins
de la province et confirme que le cas
découverts par ariane est loin d'être
isolé chaque nouveau cas en cash
vraisemblablement plusieurs ordres
c'est devenu un peu une quête je sais
pas si je peux le dire comme ça mais
pour moi c'est
c'est le summum des violences là
qu'une femme peut subir
de lui ôter ce droit de se reproduire
d'enfanter sans qu'elle ne l'ait demandé
même que je te fais 19 timon ça c'est à
moi c'est moi qui décide si tu peux
enlever mon pompe c'est mon cas
c'est mon décision puis c'est là qu'elle
a commencé à entamer des procédures pour
aller au bout de l'histoire puis pour
comprendre ce qui lui était arrivé
sa plainte aux sus mettra un an à
aboutir en attendant l'issue des
démarches a rien à récolter d'autres
récits troublants j'en ai entendu des
choses des hystérectomie sans
consentement quelqu'un qui se réveille
après une opération tout autre pour
quelque chose d'autre puis qui
a qui ont dit oui finalement on a dû
vous enlevez votre utérus on saute aux
conclusions
ariane a aussi croisé des femmes qui ont
échappé de justesse à une stérilisation
proposé lors de l'accouchement il ya une
infirmière qui arrivent et qui a
commencé à poser des questions comme
pour valider des choses donc je
répondais oui oui puis à un moment donné
la demande et oui est ce qu'on fait bien
une ligature des trompes
après la césarienne puis honnêtement
j'ai pas prêté attention à la question
parce que c'était avant d'entrer au bloc
opératoire et donc elle a dit ça a pu
marcher là oui oui puis
mon conjoint du te ment a demandé à 8 tu
veux faire ça je dis me faire quoi
le même dilemme qu'on a imposé à des
femmes autochtones
je vais je vais t'en pire
personne avec monal dans la chambre puis
on ne chôme les tpo lors je n'avais pas
j'avais peur qu'il prenne mon pb
j'étais un peu en est en stress anxiété
amanda lear faire l'opération hélas je
suis revenu à moi même je dis mais non
mais pourquoi vous voulez avoir d'autres
enfants je fais ou oui je pars c'est mon
autre enfant qui était à la maison
puisque white une romance et c'est quoi
car qu'elle est revenue
jean
je voulais pas
qu'ils aient pas fait
nous sommes partis d'un premier cas avec
avons eu un peu de scepticisme
car la pratique n'avait jamais été
documentés avant au québec en quelques
semaines les témoignages ont afflué le
fil en aiguille une confidence menant à
une autre nous avons recensé dix femmes
qui ont été stérilisés sans leur plein
consentement en plus de celles qui ont
pu l'éviter
[Musique]
moi j'étais les gars tiré à l'âge de 18
ans une grande opération jeu sa veste
quoi
mais les gars tu régis avait posté quoi
c'est au bas mot communauté j'en connais
deux couples et femmes qui ont aussi
bien
les starisation
109 points 5 mans
mais mon copain parce qu'ils m'ont dit
tu fais pour
cent au pied du mur
[Musique]
j'étais
tellement
[Musique]
j'avais non pas vraiment mais j'avais
quand
j'étais pas la passion de classiques
parce que j'étais un
migrantes sans assurance maladie est-ce
que c'était bienveillance je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas parce que ce sont pas le
genre de décisions qu'on prend la place
de quelqu'un il
ce serait pas de la bienveillance pour
moi c'est presque un crime et quelques
années plus tard je voulais avoir un
autre enfant tu c'est là que j'ai su que
je pourrais plus jamais avoir d'enfant
parce qu'ils n'ont coupé les drames a
même tenté de rouler
quand j ai de vue il dit jean fin du gel
mauvaise nouvelle dit choqué il est à
pitre autour d'une bière pour toi aidez
des temps pas coupé ils n'ont pas clip
hey you tout brûler ce fait n 2 présent
billet je me sentais pas bien
si comme ce qu'ils me sentais fini
[Musique]
je pourrais plus jamais été avec un an
tu veux des enfants
je suis après quelques mois que j'étais
je pouvais pas vraiment princesse que
tout à chaque parloir
feghouli mais
la joie d'avoir des enfants
c'est comme si encore plus je me sentais
écrasé
puis j'ai commencé à douter de moi après
j'ai commencé à douter de mes capacités
parentin je me suis longtemps que
ça ne m'a pas
comme l'arrachage nous ôte des voix le
dire
[Musique]
comme un de mes amis m'appellent souvent
tout les jours be a place et
digitick des choses aux passionnés la
bière
j'ai la rage
first une fois mort
du web
ikea.com fois
[Musique]
depuis qu'une poignée de femmes ont
dénoncé dans l'ouest une centaine
d'autres se sont manifestés mais on
soupçonne qu'il y en a eu des milliers
de toucher à l'échelle du pays depuis
que cette pratique existe
en 2018 alyssa lombard saisit de la
sphère le comité des nations unies
contre la torture
alors
32 33
semaines enceinte j'ai monté l'avion
avec la permission des médecins et je me
suis déplace à genève pour présenter à
ce comité
l'expérience le vécu
de nos clientes j'avais les mains
pleines a tout simplement expliqué à
quel point la stérilisation sans
consentement forcé c'est un traitement
qui est cruel au plein milieu du bruit
femmes bien sûr les rapporteurs 10,90
cesser la torture on a déjà des idées ça
fait longtemps
c'était quand même pas honte absolue
mais encore c'était sérieux c'était des
nous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
prévenir la pratique de la stérilisation
forcée ce qui constitue la torture en
eaux internationales des nous ce que
vous avez fait pour punir ceux qui sont
responsables examiner votre code pénal
des nous qu'est ce que vous avez fait
pour réparer
alyssa arrive à peine de genève
lorsqu'elle apprend qu'une autre femme
autochtone vient de subir une
stérilisation forcée en saskatchewan
revenir en sachant que
j'ai poussé poussé au puy le savoir que
c'est le produit
aux collines dont descend vite ton corps
c'est comme
ça ça me lever le coeur
en menant cette bataille l easa a vite
découvert que le phénomène n'est pas
unique au canada
sur tous les continents des femmes
noires autochtone rome oui murs ont été
stérilisés contre leur gré
alyssa lombard déplore qu'aucune mesure
concrète n'ait encore été adoptée par le
canada on vous assure qu'il ya des
mesures qui ont été prises lesquelles
allaient les qu'elle allait expliquer
les femmes veut savoir c'est quoi les
mesures
jusqu'à date ce qu'on voit c'est des
réunions et ce qui sauf qu'en ce moment
là les femmes c'est les familles de
leurs enfants
c'est une souffrance
[Musique]
la mort de joyce et chaque fois nous a
appris que la parole d'une femme
autochtone celle d'une femme racisées ne
fait pas toujours le poids devant celle
de l'establishment médicale voici la
conclusion de l'histoire de maria et la
réaction du collège des médecins
[Applaudissements]
alik à la fontaine est le premier
médecin autochtone qui deviendra bientôt
président de l'association médicale
canadienne
non seulement il reconnaît la
responsabilité des médecins dans la
pratique des stérilisations et posé il a
le courage d'admettre sa propre
expérience
[Musique]
mais sauf
à paris
il faut vraiment avoir un talent des
roues à travers le système de santé pour
dire non à ces pratiques c'est politique
colonial qui continuent à ses jours
une de ces pratiques dont samir a été
témoin l'arrivée à l'urgence d'enfants
autochtones malades blessés évacués du
grand nord sans aucun accompagnement moi
j'ai essayé d'être très claires par le
fait que moi j'ai participé dans cette
pratique ignoble qui existe depuis des
décennies donc je ne prétends pas être
quelqu'un qui est pur ou qui avaient qui
ne faisait pas partie de ça je faisais
partie mais ça veut ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne peut pas un moment donné rompre
essayer de confronter
ces pratiques et jeu ça l'a poussé à
agir et à faire changer les choses il
appelle ses confrères médecins a dénoncé
eux aussi les pratiques coloniales comme
la stérilisation est posée
il ya un esprit de corps et à l'impunité
qui existent aussi je pense pas que les
gens toutes ces stérilisation auront pu
ce faire toutes ces années là s'il n'y
avait pas un sentiment d'impunité
on ne peut pas quand même pratique et la
ligature des trompes de force sur une
femme il faut quand même leur
autorisation et dans certains cas une
autorisation écrite
[Musique]
en janvier 2020 maria reçoit enfin la
réponse de l'hôpital où elles auraient
été les gars tuerie contre son plein gré
ce qui donne du poids à sa version de
l'histoire c'est qu'elle n'a jamais
signé de formulaires de consentement
pour une procédure de stérilisation une
omission reconnaît le sus c'est une
omission
c'est une erreur grave
c'est un faute grave
le sus retient tout de même la version
du médecin il est d'avis que mariah a
dit oui à une ligature il admet
toutefois que oui accordé quelques
minutes avant l'intervention ne valait
pas grand chose il questionne la qualité
de ce consentement je suis d'avis qu'il
est possible de conclure que l'état dans
lequel vous étiez dans ces minutes qui
ont précédé votre césarienne et pu
altérer votre compréhension de la
chirurgie stérilisons proposée dans la
note réponse à la qualité du
consentement a pas été respecté
c'est quoi la conséquence
insatisfaite maria se tourner vers le
collège des médecins il retient lui
aussi la version selon laquelle elle
aurait consenti en admettant que le
moment n'était pas idéale mais le
collège ne blâment la médecin ni pour
l'absence de signature au formulaire de
consentement ni pour avoir proposé une
stérilisation alors que mariah était
vulnérable en plein accouchement la
docteure soutient s'être dit qu'il était
de son devoir de vous informer de
l'option de la ligature tubert
mais ce qu'on m'a donné à cette femme là
la possibilité d'aller chercher par
exemple un deuxième avis puisque ce
n'était pas une situation urgente
donc merci docteur
de prendre ce devoir là coeur donnez-moi
toutes les informations puis je vais
aller faire mes recherches je vais
prendre ma décision je la réfléchir on a
soumis au collège des médecins les
conclusions de notre enquête
vous savez que je peux pas commenter
publiquement de corps particulier
mais devant l'ampleur possible du
problème le président du collège à
l'intention de rappeler les médecins à
l'ordre je suis très mal à l'aise avec
ça très préoccupé par le fait qu'il
puisse y avoir au québec des
stérilisations d'euros consentie je vous
dis qu'il ya un rappel qui va être fait
pour que
de telles décisions se faire dans les
meilleures circonstances possibles ou
permettre à la patiente de prendre la
meilleure décision pour elle comme
professionnel il faut laisser
le temps toutefois le collège refuse
d'émettre une directive qui était
redirai aux médecins de proposer la
stérilisation à une femme qui accouche
ça pourtant été la première mesure
adoptée par saskatoon dès 2016 pour moi
ça ne vient pas nécessairement par une
directive explicite mais plutôt par une
prise de conscience une sensibilisation
à la possibilité de l'un d'eux est bien
conscient j'en avais moi aussi
aucun des établissements visés dans ce
reportage n'a voulu commenter de cas
spécifiques
la plupart se sont engagés à améliorer
le lien de confiance avec les patientes
et à faire des efforts pour compris le
racisme
on est encore loin des solutions
préconisées par les nations unies
prévenir certes mais faut-il punir
criminaliser ou retirés par exemple le
droit de pratiquer un médecin fautif
est
juste ou non
le canada va t'il réparer va-t-il et
denise et les victimes comme l'ont fait
plusieurs états américains
car des excuses ne suffiront pas estime
l'avocate alice allons pas une excuse
sans changement comportement est quand
même assez vide
c'est mieux que rien mais à mon avis non
clientes et les femmes autochtones qui
sont en train de donner naissance se
mérite beaucoup plus qu'un c'est mieux
que rien dans le cas de maria est pour a
part avoir s'est trompé pour
mais un peu de dignité d'êtres messiah
personnes qui en parle dans les
conclusions
la personne qui parle d'elle de son
sentiment elle c'est comme si un
cicatrice qui est là qui veut qu c'est
un bleu su
même que ça aguerris se retourne c'est
comme ça jamais guéri pour la vie
[Musique]
est arrivé ça ça me touche beaucoup
parce que je fais partie de ses gains je
me dis pourquoi ne pas mentir on est des
êtres humains cerny tout pareil
c'est juste une femme atteinte suffit à
dallas est aussi
geipan de marrast
[Musique]
ce contact des femmes qui parlent qu'ils
sont capables de parler même si après
des années je me suis sentie par une
bonne main basse chief jura puis je vois
avec mes enfants que je suis une bonne
heure
oui
[Musique]
vous avez certainement été ému par les
témoignages mais peut-être que pour
certaines d'entre vous c'est encore plus
bouleversant plus personnel on a mis des
ressources sur notre site internet ainsi
qu'une entrevue avec la chercheuse suzy
basile de l'université du québec en
abitibi qui mène présentement une étude
sur le sujet des stérilisations est
posée c'est tout pour nous au nom de
toute l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là revenez nous la semaine prochaine
pour une autre enquête
[Musique]